[Música]
spectrum
te has puesto a pensar como la inocente
petición de una pequeña niña puede
transformar todo el hospital
te has puesto a pensar en lo que puede
lograr la magia de un sueño de una niña
quisiera contarte un cuento
qué sucede en un país muy muy lejano
pero más bien te voy a contar una
historia que sucede muy cerca de ti y es
que a lo mejor no es difícil hacerle una
petición a un doctor que se disfraza
esta historia empezó en 2015 cuando adam
malysz le pidió a su doctor doctor mis
papás me compraron un disfraz de
princesa quiero venir en mi próxima
consulta de princesa y que tú vengas de
príncipe o de rey así yo seré la
princesa y tú serás el príncipe puede
ser en mi siguiente consulta un gigante
que en tu próxima consulta vendrá
santacruz y en la de enero yo no voy a
estar qué te parece si lo hacemos para
febrero
con este acuerdo ella se fue muy
contenta y su doctor o entendió mal o
empezó a soltar la imaginación
cualquiera podía decir que se volvió
loco porque una tarde dijo
qué tal si en vez de que solo de armar
is que es privilegiada porque sus papás
se pueden comprar un disfraz de princesa
logramos que todas las niñas del
hospital civil de guadalajara que
acuerdan la consulta en los cines se
vistan de princesas no sé cómo lo voy a
hacer porque viendo 300 consultas al mes
y la mitad de ellas niñas va a ser
difícil sin embargo inocentemente se me
ocurrió postear en el facebook la
petición de damaris
pero algo modificada
no sé qué te parece si me ayudas a crear
un momento de magia e ilusión para las
niñas que acuerda la clínica de leucemia
del nuevo hospital civil de guadalajara
damaris que quiere acudir como princesa
vamos a buscar que todas las niñas sean
princesas y vivan un momento de magia e
ilusión cuando acudan a su consulta de
febrero así es que si tienes un disfraz
nuevo o usado de princesa en buen estado
regala vuelo para que estas niñas puedan
vivir un momento de magia e ilusión
muchas gracias
no imaginé lo que iba a pasar con suerte
tendría quince o veinte disfraces que
comprarían entre mi mamá mi hermana mi
familia y quizás cinco despistados que
leían el mensaje en el facebook y les
pareciera buena idea
antes de pasar 24 horas mi sobrina llegó
a regalarme todos disfraces
tres días ya tenía otros cuatro que me
regaló mi hermana dos que me regaló mi
familia cinco que me regaló mi mamá y
antes de pasar una semana al llegar aquí
a guadalajara ya estaba en todos los
chats de kwanzas imágenes haciendo
promoción a la campaña pidiendo que
donarán los disfraces y todo mundo
preguntaba en la página de facebook
donde están los centros oficiales de
recolección los oficiales de recolección
no había ninguno no había yo pensado que
esta campaña se fuera extender tanto
fue tan el alcance de este sueño y tan
la generosidad de toda la sociedad de
guadalajara y de otras partes del país
que a las 18 días de lanzada la
propuesta pública que por favor ya no me
mandaran más disfraces que ya teníamos
más de los que podíamos manejar porque
no teníamos un equipo no teníamos una
bodega no teníamos ni idea de cómo le
íbamos a hacer
bueno pues pareció que esa fue la
invitación para que llegaran más porque
a partir de ese día no paraban de llegar
trajes de princesa encantadores todos en
excelente estado algunos si no nos
íbamos a poder utilizar pero la mayor
parte estaban excelentes los medios me
invitaron a los programas de radio de
televisión para quisiera yo preparar la
campaña y con mucha pena lo que yo hacía
era darle las gracias a toda la gente
que nos había donado que ya no nos
sonarán más y bueno pues esto
multiplicaba la petición para que
llegaran más y más cuando llevamos 1800
de contar ya lo que habíamos aquí en la
casa no teníamos una bodega decidimos
empezar a empaquetar los dos metimos en
cajas será nuestra cochera desapareció
prácticamente la planta baja nos
convertimos probablemente la más grande
bodega de disfraces de princesa
reciclados la gente vació sus clases la
gente vació sus corazones y nos dio toda
esa magia así es que bueno finalmente ya
por tener el día tuve que localizar a
damaris y decirle que sus citas iba a
anticipar y bueno pues también fuimos
preparando a nuestras niñas cuando
salían en su consulta de enero para
programar la consulta de febrero la
recepcionista les entregaba una
invitación en un sobre lacrado como si
fuera la invitación a un baile de sus de
cuentos al sacar la invitación se les
decía que su majestuosa presencia sería
agradecida en la consulta para el mes de
febrero
todo estaba listo el primer día
voluntarios nos donaron la decoración
una decoración fabulosa todo todo estaba
en su punto para que la madre llegara a
inaugurar su sueño hecho realidad no
sólo para ella sino para todas las niñas
que acudían a la consulta de oncología y
hematología del nuevo hospital civil de
guadalajara
se dieron cita los medios cuando se
abrió la puerta del elevador para todos
aquellos que llegaban ese día a la
consulta había una fachada de un
castillo hecha con globos pasaron a la
sala de espera de siempre y quedaban
sentados a debajo de una carroza también
hecha con globos había adornos de
princesas a todo lo largo y una alfombra
roja para conducirlos al interior del
constructor
lo que normalmente en una sala de espera
de un hospital ante sala de
procedimientos ante sala de
quimioterapia ante sala de consultas
quedó convertido en un lugar mágico
parecía más un salón de fiestas que una
sala de espera de hospital
teníamos nuestras voluntarias modistas
listas para elegir trajes de los racks
para cualquier niña que llegara a
solicitar todos los programas me
contaron cuando en su evento doctor el
evento va a ser todos los días porque
cada día que nos levantamos es especial
y queremos que todos los días nuestras
niñas vivan con esa magia con esa
ilusión que siempre encuentren que a
pesar del dolor a pesar de la enfermedad
puede existir la ternura la magia el
amor en sus vidas que recuerden que son
niñas que pueden tener todos los sueños
que quieran por alcanzar
invitamos a damaris que pasó frente a
las cámaras
caminó por la alfombra roja la recibimos
con una rosa pasó a la consulta se sentó
en un trono rosa la coronamos tomamos
las fotos salió en todos los medios y se
fue viviendo un momento mágico en su
vida y todo ese mes de febrero del 2016
todas las niñas que asistieron a la
consulta a procedimientos a
quimioterapias cada vez que iban a
importa que fueran más de una vez podían
tener un vestido increíble mágico para
llevárselo y hacerlo parte de su vida
no quedó ahí
cada año en febrero se reproduce esta
experiencia para el siguiente año
incorporamos a los varones y entonces la
campaña fue princesas heroínas y
superhéroes contra el cáncer y desde
entonces cada año se vuelca la
generosidad de muchas partes del país
para el nuevo hospital civil de
guadalajara y sus niños hemos recibido
más de 9 mil trajes imagínate a cuántos
niños ya cuántas niñas les hemos
regalado un momento de magia e ilusión
no subestimes la petición de los más
pequeños de aquellos que parece que no
tienen voz para cambiar la realidad
no tengas miedo a volverte loco creyendo
en la magia de un sueño que puede
cambiar el dolor por alegría
así es que la próxima vez que un niño te
pida algo
escúchalo quizás la petición llegue a
los corazones adecuados
puedas lograr un cambio
en tu país cercano todos los días